during the winter school will be a
series of different sessions some of
them will be plenary talks speaking
about different aspects of the science
of consciousness but there'll also be
some social events so you get to
interact with leading researchers
leading consciousness researchers it's a
unique opportunity for young scientists
to get engaged with people
they've read their papers of we've all
had this experience as scientists
of actually meeting for the first time
one of the people we admire or one of
the people who disagree with for one of
the people who influenced our work
people get divided into teams they've
become these little communities and they
get to work on projects and they have a
lot of time outside of
just lecture time to interact both
socially and scientifically and i think
that really builds relationships that
last
and at the end of it i think you'll come
away equipped with a whole lot of skills
and experience that will be really
valuable in your academic career or in
fact in whatever you want to do next
you